ff9 Hahn of Justice is coming our way
yes but nobody knows how and we're gonna
find out welcome reject nation my name
is John Humphrey
I'm Greg Alba and we are part of the
fast family welcome to the reject family
mother effers yeah there you go we're
gonna check out this video today from a
channel called looper we love their
movie lists we often disagree with them
though but today we're gonna check out a
think piece you know for that do we know
it's much movie well you know I don't
know I'll take a lead here now since you
make us look terrible
yeah let's cover a looper video just say
we disagree with them often geez John
well that's what we say well I'm not
sure the one time I look whatever of
second chances around here not even for
Shaw with a burst trailer from the 9th
Fast & Furious film dropped at the past
9 Festival in Miami on January 31st
bands in the nearly two decades long
action a shocking surprise after winning
over audiences in 2006 is the Fast and
the Furious Tokyo Drift on Lu the
effortlessly cool street racer thief
businessman and former member of Dominic
Toretto's crew is back from the dead yes
sir my son Kang he died in the third
fast and furious movie the 1st and the
franchise directed by Justin Lin though
he appeared in the next three films the
sagas timeline put his death after the
events of 6 the spans have believed for
more than a decade that Hans fate and
the universe had been sealed
her dad got some crazy in Tokyo yeah
trailer characteristically snacking is
he enters a room full of his former
crewmates this of course begs a question
how is Han still alive after audiences
saw him die it doesn't matters covered
claims to know the answer he's got a
brother Owen with a grain of salt but
the outlet alleges that on simply
escaped his car before it became
enveloped in flames unidentified and
unverified sources close to the ampoules
like the Lennon and Heidi staying under
the radar of those he knows with the
after and following the fateful incident
the site's also reported that the
character will make an appearance in the
sagas tenth and final film slated for an
April 20-21 release however Han Liu
makes his long-desired return in f9 the
news of his survival has been a shot of
adrenaline to the fanbase in the past
franchise after being with each other
for more than a decade the cast is
evolved into a family as much as the
characters have han was a huge part of
that which helped convince director
justin lin to bring the character back
in to Dom's family and back into the
past universe as Lin told Entertainment
Weekly I think it's really up to us to
bring him back and explore it throughout
the themes that were all used to the
Vans certainly seem happy on Twitter the
announcement that Han would return got
the hashtag han is alive trending it
also appeared to renew the trust of fast
diehards who felt betrayed by the movies
after he gave Hans killer Deckard Shaw
prime billing in two films following the
popular character's death as it happens
Lin has a long history with ha that's
why Xavier shot onto his feelings talent
to crime dramatist Ronaldo signed on
tomorrow actor song Kang revealed in a
2013 interview with mandatory that Han
was added to the Fast and Furious
franchise only after Lin convinced the
executives to change up another proposed
character clearly Han is not only
beloved by the past fandom he's also a
character Lin is carried with him
throughout his career mod is a prime
example of the narrative the Fast and
Furious saga has built around found
family and that may be important going
into the next film
Lin is certainly not made in the
characters return lightly you told
Entertainment Weekly in this world I
feel like things happen for a reason I
won't go into details or anything but I
do think that bringing him back is
nothing I take lightly fans back a lot
but I think what I appreciate is that
this universe has really grown and it
allows us to evolve and really kind
redefine ourselves as we go as I'm
itself would say I've simple to make
choices and you don't look back as for
some Kang the experience of returning to
the screen is the fan-favorite is this
big for him as it is for the fans who
had desperately wanted to see him back
he told the Los Angeles Times it's
emotional it feels like I'm going back
to a family reunion it's a relationship
that has been missing in my life since
the last batch see Han Liu make is lat
what's even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bells you know miss
a single one oh wow last fast last I
just want them to do fast ten now just
call what last fast
no serious last fast and then about them
supporting a cause so they're starving
themselves yeah and then they died was
what it's the last fast yeah because
it's you know the end of their she's
lying about cars but then they'll come
back in the second half of part 10 which
will be called final furious see fin
wants to make a two part ten and so I
think together we can make this perfect
and then everyone gets to come back from
the dead in this trailer for two you
know I don't really care what the
explanation is of why he's back you
could have all the theories you want you
just say is back and I'll be like
alright rules don't matter I'm rolling
why not what do they say in this video
that he probably just crawled out of the
car before it came over Glenn I guess
that's who cares
I think this franchise has become I
really hope that they do an agents of
shield type thing with this where they
make like how Han came back like
integral to the entire story I make at
this central mystery I don't mean to
sound you know insensitive to those who
are actually passionate about the family
angle would fasten the Furious I've
always thought it was funny I've always
thought it was cute but I've always felt
like people like Justin Linda Vin Diesel
I'm sure the cast feels like a family
for the amount of films they've done
together and whatnot and the fact that
it's in the script and so what they're
doing and I'm sure their perception the
idea of family is truly relevant
prevailing a thing amongst our
conversation and how they're emotionally
attached to this franchise but on my
side a fan of this franchise is someone
who really does love watching these
films we saw birds of prey in theaters
and when that trailer came up this next
Fast and Furious movie I was having such
a great time like I love watching these
films I do but the whole thing with
family is just so ham-fisted and just
such a backdrop to everything else that
I really enjoy about it I wouldn't want
the movie to do without it I just love
that when the filmmakers talk about it
as if it's like the driving force behind
this franchise yeah and if it's some
kind of like ongoing dramatic you know
tale like a saga of a family that isn't
just a vehicle for a lot of vehicular
stunts yeah because I love the debate
and the argument I'd like witnessing it
should we like the Jason Statham Shaw
character justice for Hahn should be
served I have enjoyed that conversation
I really have but do I really have a dog
in this fight you don't I mean dude what
am I really like invested have I been
like screw you Shaw can't like you
because of what you did to Han no not
really because it's the fastest
franchise lately it's been hitting me
that there must be fans who really are
passionate about such a thing that they
are invested in Bloor characters and you
consider this an a universe in and of
itself because whenever I hear you're
thrown around for this franchise like
really yeah there's everything like a
spin-off and then calling something a
universe you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah yeah The Fast and Furious to me has
kind of become like a comic book series
that's how I look at them even though
they're connected I've started to take
this approach of like okay each time the
reality is gonna reset a little bit
somebody who was bad guy last time I
might be a good guy this time or might
be kind of in the middle as like you
know comic book characters always
flip-flop like that that's kind of the
best justification I have able to bring
in for the Fast and Furious existing the
way it does the family element I feel
like is endearing partly because of the
cheese factor that comes with the
contrasting flavors of the movies you
make people make fun of it
the thing that you poked a lot of fun a
family clinking Coronas and stuff and I
guess that's the whole thing that I'm
talking about with the filmmakers is
they take it seriously while it seems
like on the audience and we make fun of
that we like it we want it there but
it's really just silly
yeah whereas to them it's like being a
part of a play yeah yeah we've done this
task for months on end we've bonded
we've been through hell together we've
created a piece of art for them I do
kind of understand where that drive
comes from but there was a cigarette oh
hey now we're in Dr shirt and he's at
Drive fest appears man when am I gonna
get my big break in comedy transmission
oh we get it what I interject a joke and
you lose your train of thought I wonder
if they're aware of the audience
perspective truly because I'm sure that
there is a certain amount of you know
just seeing like oh people were really
really excited and just kind of taking
that as a homogenized kind of love I
don't know how tie and cheek these
movies are intended to be I don't know
how self-aware of those things they are
I thought they were but I thought that
when they talk about it it doesn't sound
like they are like do you think this is
absolutely badass and absolutely you
know whatever family nugget you want to
call it yeah I don't really care how
they're fine it's a new issue yeah every
to me it excites me because I like
participating in the fun never pissed
off at Chasen's I honestly I wasn't even
aware that it was a problem to other
people I would like some cake in that
role and I wanted to see that I'm back
yeah I think he's very charming
does this mean we can open up the door
to get gal gadot back is he gonna
address that I will want there to be
some answers if it's just they cut to
some cheesy flashback where he's
crawling out of a burning vehicle fine
okay I do want some answers as to we're
together what Hawaii
why is he why is he been gone for so
long does he just like sad that
this girl was named Giselle just
Isabelle I forget some of that flash
Johnsbury why is he now appearing you
know either way any answer will be don't
really let that sink this franchise is
fun the first few films up until park
for it seem like that they were trying
to ground themselves in reality then
when it got ridiculous it was like this
movie's stupid and they kind of did the
inverse of that you know and that's when
the franchise has really seen you know
to found some real fuel so guys why do
you think Hahn is back are you one of
the furiously passionate fans of the
fast franchise are you like actually
emotionally invested in the characters
to the degree where you were like just
as Vermont huh huh or justice wrong
which one are you subscribe to looper
thank you so much Prince together as a
great one subscriber the real rejects
click that notification bell so you can
get accepted to the reject family and
last but not least it's time for up Cal
Dorian see Pittacus been enjoying
chatting with this gentleman aspiring
writer has all day universe building
ideas in his own mind right now even
with shout out last month and we talked
about how his name can sounds like it
could be like a superhero or a badass
character sorts and he said to me I
haven't told my name fits in Star Wars
MK lotr and L I don't want to say the
whole I'm flattered but I'm sure I'd be
a good hero that eventually goes dark
hint my favorite superhero so I guess
the superhero havoc he's saying that's
not correct he said to think 70s I have
no clue who he's talking about or which
his favorite superhero is my throat's a
John who do you think is super Errol is
seventies go star I throw it to you guys
to which one is it I'm just gonna go out
on a limb and say it's Spectre who's
like a cop character who gets gunned
down and comes back as a ghost superhero
cuz you know if you're a ghost in a
superhero you can go dark probably I
assume
right called durian I mean if you've got
that dark streak in you I think maybe
you should put that to good use you
could be in the Fast and Furious you
know but the problem is you would have
to be just a straight-up villain based
off his little thumbnail he could
probably in the Hobbs universe well yeah
yeah because then you could be like a
super charged up extra enhanced soldier
with like a hemi built into your body or
something like that you know I was just
saying is the rocks Brown he's brown oh
yeah the hakka see in a way would call
me you out for being brown brown when we
do the Samoa scenes then just lump you
into a category